[Music]
on this Sunday night tension intensifies
the war of words as China defends
buzzing a U.S warship in international
waters accidents can happen that could
cause things to spiral out of control we
need to be Eyes Wide Open on China the
top level talks and next steps after our
exclusive reporting and that close
encounter in the Taiwan Straits
new details as investigators dig into
the cause of India's deadly real
disaster
heard of quiet quitting what about stay
interviews a retention issue could
relate to how an employee is being
managed the new post-pandemic labor
market buzzword building a better
Workforce
and from the paralympic podium to
real-life heroism I got a call from
Jessica I've got
Canadian athlete and her canines
incredible rescue
global national with para Nasser
good evening to you and thank you for
joining us we begin tonight with the
super power blame game in the wake of
our exclusive reporting from the
indo-pacific region where our Global
News crew witnessed firsthand a Chinese
warship buzzing a U.S Navy destroyer in
the Taiwan Strait our camera captured
this dangerous maneuver on Saturday a
close encounter the U.S says was
intentional speaking at a top level
security Summit in Singapore today U.S
defense secretary Lloyd Austin labeled
China's actions irresponsible and called
on China to rein in that kind of conduct
conduct that could cause things to
spiral out of control
the Taiwan Strait which is in the
disputed South China Sea lies within
international waters but China says
freedom of navigation patrols by other
countries are a provocation our McKenzie
gray is aboard hmcs Montreal with the
very latest Mackenzie
Farah hmcs Montreal has left the Taiwan
straight but the busy Seas we saw there
have followed us on our journey
as we move into the East China Sea so
does the people's Liberation Army Navy
continuing to Shadow the Canadian
American warships on a joint Mission
traveling through international waters
but the traffic increased today first
but the pot of dolphins alongside the
Montreal then with an Australian and a
Japanese warship meeting up for a new
Mission essentially we're going to be
just working with multinational Partners
to promote the free and open
indo-pacific region the Chinese ship
launched one of their helicopters
circling the Montreal twice before
flying off and actually not viewed as
concerning by the Canadians they'll send
out their helicopters to see who's
operating off their Coast figure out who
we are where we are and they try to
figure out what we're doing but we try
to keep that to ourselves the new
exercise pre-planned and not a response
to yesterday's close call between USS
Chong hoon and a Chinese warship in the
Taiwan Strait a maneuver the Chinese
defense minister defended
calling the joint Canada U.S Mission a
provocation to China saying the United
States is truly the primary cause of
tensions in the South China Sea
but our exclusive video from yesterday
tells another story
the Chinese warship steaming across from
the left cutting off the Chung Hoon only
150 yards from its bow after telling the
Americans on the radio to move or get
hit
the Chang Hoon needing to slow down to
avoid a collision American indo-pacific
command calling the maneuver unsafe and
a violation of Maritime rules this is a
clearly provocative and and arguably
unprofessional event
um and I would say that you know the
Chinese Captain knew exactly what he was
doing this was not an accident as you
can see behind us the Montreal has met
up with the Canadian refueling ship the
asterisk which was providing Diesel and
other supplies para but the final leg of
our journey
looking forward to more of your coverage
Mackenzie gray aboard hmcs Montreal
thank you
now the close encounter captured by our
Global News crew has triggered a war of
words between China and the U.S and
deepening discussions among defense
ministers meeting at a top level
security Summit in Singapore this
weekend where the state of China's
relationship with Western Powers
including Canada Australia and the U.S
is very much in the spotlight David Akin
reports on the high hopes of preparing
frayed relations
days ago it was this Chinese Air Force
fighter jet buzzing a U.S reconnaissance
plane then Saturday it was a Chinese
Corvette cutting off a U.S Destroyer the
U.S defense secretary said Sunday these
are dangerous provocations that must
stop I call upon
the prc's leadership to to really
do the right things to rein in that kind
of conduct because I think uh accidents
can happen that could cause things to
spiral out of control but the West's
contest with China is not just about
planes and ships there are
confrontations over semiconductors and
trade over cyber security threats to
infrastructure and in Canada and
elsewhere allegations of Chinese foreign
interference we need to be Eyes Wide
Open on China and the fact is that they
have become an increasingly disruptive
Global power and that really fuels our
view in our indo-pacific strategy that
we must be eyes wide open with regards
to this country Canada will boost its
military presence in the region with
plans to deploy three Navy frigates to
the Pacific next year up from two this
year China though believes these are
examples of the West trying to contain
it in the same way NATO's strategy was
about containing Russia and this Chinese
military officer at the Singapore
security Summit suggested that the
West's containment strategy provoked the
war in Ukraine have you ever
thought that whether this way of
continuing itself
is a problem
or it's a kind of failure proved by the
war in Ukraine thank you hours after
this Summit in Singapore ended Sunday
the U.S said it would send a top state
department official to Beijing next week
to Spur talks aimed at easing tensions
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
now to the escalating Wildfire fight
threatening communities right across
Canada forcing thousands of people from
their homes
from BC to the Atlantic provinces there
are nearly 400 active wildfires burning
across our country and more than 200
remain out of control most of the fires
are in Quebec we're going to have more
on that situation in a moment but first
there is some reprieve coming out of
Nova Scotia tonight whereas Mike
Armstrong reports some of the province's
worst wildfires ever recorded are now
contained
largest wildfire in Nova scotia's
history is now at least not growing the
rain this weekend was enough to stop it
from spreading it is fantastic to see
not a person is complaining out there I
met with Cruz last night they were
stopping wet when they got back off the
fire line but they were smiles the
Shelburne fire covers about 250 square
kilometers but enough of it is contained
that the evacuation order is being
lifted for some areas and an important
Highway in the region the 103 will
reopen Monday evacuees say the progress
isn't just the weather but also credit
firefighters they're wonderful they're
tired they're exhausted but they keep on
trucking to save our homes
and I want to be a fireman when I grow
up
pretend Town fire outside Halifax
progress the fire is now 100 percent
contained but about 150 homes were
destroyed and there's still an
evacuation order in place for hundreds
of others some neighborhoods have
reopened more will reopen soon there are
homes that made it through the fire that
are inside what are being called areas
of significant impact the homes around
them have been destroyed
most residents may not be allowed home
the city says for 10 to 14 days
a regular life has returned to some
reopened communities but there are
changes the Stillwater Lake development
was built with only two ways in or out
for hundreds of homes and they lead to
the same road last Sunday when the
evacuation was ordered it meant people
trying to get to safety were in a
bottleneck we were probably about 45
minutes from the time we left our
driveway to the highway and how long
would that take normally
six minutes well under emergency Powers
the city is adding emergency exits to
some developments this new road runs
from Stillwater Lake directly to the
highway the exits will be locked and
only opened in an emergency the hope is
they'll never be needed Mike Armstrong
Global News upper 10 Talon Nova Scotia
in Quebec there are nearly twice as many
fires burning this year compared to the
average number of fires over the past 10
years
there's about 141 fire all over all over
Quebec and our fire firefighters are
still fighting 35 of those why 35 it's
because we concentrate our battle on
this fire because we want to protect
human life
around 14 000 people across Quebec have
been forced to leave their homes as
flames inch closer officials say 100
members if the Canadian Armed Forces are
being deployed Into the Fire zones
arriving tonight to help with the
firefight on the ground
and staying in Quebec where search
efforts have been called off after the
body of a missing man was recovered in
the St Lawrence River late Saturday
following a tragic fishing trip that
also claimed the lives of four children
the man in his 30s was one of 11 people
fishing along the shore when the group
was swept up by a rising tide the four
children all minor is older than 10
years old were found unresponsive on the
bank and pronounced dead soon after the
rest of the group was rescued from the
water
now to India were at least 275 are dead
and some 1200 others wounded after that
country's worst whale crash in more than
two decades Railway officials are
pointing to a signaling system failure
as the likely cause of Friday's disaster
involving three trains as Redmond
Shannon reports even more clues are
emerging surrounding the cause and those
at fault
clings to fading hope and to a photo of
her missing husband at this makeshift
morgue she is tasked with looking for
him among the bodies to some relief he
isn't there
I've been to all the hospitals and
nothing I just need my husband I don't
want anything else
back at the crash site hope is gone the
rescue operation over and the cleanup
now well underway train carriages have
been pushed aside to get the track
reopened soon but the devastation is no
less evident the brutal crash on Friday
took hundreds of lives and ruined many
more details of how that happened are
gradually becoming clear officials say
one of the passenger trains was
traveling south from Kolkata to Chennai
it appears to have ended up on a side
track where it hit a parked freight
train the derailed carriages were then
hit by carriages of another passenger
train that was traveling north on Sunday
an official at India's Railway board
said they're keeping their minds open no
nothing is ruled up but she did indicate
they believed there was an issue with
the signaling system however India's
Railway Minister says the calls and the
people responsible have now been
identified although he did didn't
elaborate whoever did it and whatever
are the reasons will be known after
investigation Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi has said anyone found
responsible will face the strictest
punishment large trained disasters like
this had once been common in India and
many small accidents continue to happen
but safety has been improving in recent
decades this crash a wake-up call that
more work needs to be done for the
millions who use this enormous Network
every day Redmond challenge Global News
London
population growth and political promises
coming up why industry experts say the
solution to tackling Canada's house
Market isn't just about building more
[Music]
Canada's housing crisis is nearing its
boiling point in 2022 the Canada
mortgage and housing Corporation
reported that Canada needs to build 5.8
million new homes by 2030 to help
achieve housing affordability it's
critical that happens because just last
year this country's population grew by
more than a million people that's a
record immigration accounts for 96 of
that growth
as Mike drawlay reports for average
families chasing the Canadian dream it's
an absolute nightmare
it doesn't make sense whatever
whatever's Happening Now doesn't make
sense from his downtown Toronto balcony
a housing market filled water once saw
as attainable is now anything but we
were putting in bids and we thought we
were being competitive you know we would
go
you know a hundred two hundred thousand
dollars over the asking price and we
were getting outbid by a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand dollars
water and his family are in the same
boat as so many other Canadians double
income household good jobs a kid and a
dog and in need of more living space but
they're stuck in a condo downtown you
should be able to afford a house in
theory we should yeah
in reality not so much
they could buy a house but water doesn't
want to live an hour and a half away
from his job an extended family in the
city and besides critics like
environmental defense worry about the
impact urban sprawl will have on
pollution the affordability crisis
related to actually be able to have
homes that people can afford to pay the
mortgage on and that are in places where
people actually want to live critics
also argue Canada's current housing
crisis shouldn't have come as a surprise
housing starts simply haven't kept up
with population growth to catch up
Ontario in particular is getting
ambitious with plans to build 1.5
million homes over the next decade it's
a promise that's going to be hard to
keep the last time in this province that
we built 750 000 homes in in any 10-year
period was between 1973 and 1982. so
basically 40 to 50 years ago we have a
plan to federally Justin Trudeau has set
a goal of 2.5 million homes over the
next decade the bottom line is that
industry experts see all those promises
as a glass house and the only solutions
appear to be bricks I think 24 Sussex is
the perfect symbol for a country that
struggles to get housing right if we
can't house the Prime Minister and their
family you know we're in a load of
trouble the prime minister's rundown
residence hasn't been occupied in years
and with estimates to fix it running in
the tens of millions of dollars does it
even make sense given the larger housing
crisis
microlight Global News Toronto
[Music]
is there doing to stop
quitting
in a post-pandemic labor market we're
seeing new trends emerge from quite
quitting to the great resignation well
now there's a new workplace Buzz term
the stay interview and gaviola explains
you're probably familiar with interviews
to get you hired and exit interviews
after you decide to leave but a newly
popular workplace trend is a stay
interview what essentially you're
determining is why an employee wants to
stay with a particular employer and
maybe even why they'd want to leave a
stay interview also known as an
engagement interview helps employers
figure out how to make an employee who
may be on the fence stay in a
competitive labor market with nearly 1
million unfilled positions across Canada
employment experts say the trend is a
game changer interviews cover a range of
topics that make a big difference in an
employee's life like the flexibility to
leave early to pick up kids from school
or take a pet for a walk since adopting
stay interviews in 2017 the BC Maritime
employers Association has seen dramatic
results in terms of retention and
employee engagement we went from 2017
having approximately 25 percent of our
staff engaged at work to having 78 last
year successful stay interviews aren't
conducted by a direct boss there is I
would say some virtue in having a stay
interview conducted by HR or maybe not a
direct manager or supervisor because a
retention issue could relate to how an
employee is being managed and successful
engagement interviews lead to changes
free pandemic they had been able to get
together and go out for dinners or go
out and do genuine activities together
whether it be hiking or go-karting or
any sort of fun activity so that they
could bond as human beings rather than
just employees talking about work in
this case the return of team bonding
experiences anything employers can do to
get a leg up on their competition and
help them keep their best workers is a
must employers that are not able to do
that they're the ones that are
challenged in terms of being able to
retain their employees and that's having
a negative impact in terms of you know
their ability to sort of rebound I think
stay interviews are critical because not
only do you learn about an employee's
experience but also it helps you to get
information for the organization to
recalibrate in our post pandemic new
workplace environment where demands and
priorities have shifted stay interviews
can help companies Survive and Thrive
and gaviola Global News Toronto
[Music]
next a former paralympian and her guide
dog going above and beyond the Call of
Duty
[Music]
now to an incredible story out of BC
where a paralympian with a visual
impairment and her specially trained
golden retriever managed to track down a
missing person with dementia as Kylie
Stanton reports how they did it is
simply remarkable
when it comes to Blazing Trails Jessica
tawamala is a bit of a master I've been
Elite athlete and I went to three
paralympic games as a swimmer got really
intrigued by Triathlon and so when it
came to adding scent trailing to the
list a method of search and rescue that
involves tracking the sense of missing
persons the 39 year old was up for the
challenge started reaching out to
different organizations and different
companies across Canada and across the
U.S trying to see if there was anyone
who would want to work with me about
where Lucy comes in I am completely
blind I trust a dog to keep me safe and
like and you know keep me alive
essentially
but now together they're keeping others
alive as well so your head a little
pressure the pair trained extensively
with the help of sent evidence canine
based in Tallahassee Florida good girl
whether it's a child an elderly person
with memory loss or vulnerable member of
society Lucy can now track a person's
scent this is a very simple tool what's
proven even more effective if it's
called preservation kit prior to the
search event everybody sent specific to
themselves so it's just like your DNA or
your fingerprint we've actually done
trails and trials with identical twins
and the dogs are able to peek between
the two
elderly neighbor went missing the duo
had a chance to put that training to the
test the woman's scent which had been
captured and stored was presented to
Lucy and off they went took us over
three kilometers
um and about just over 40 minutes and
then what in no time I got a call from
Jessica I've got her she's alive
it would Mark the 400
190 percent evidence canine and its
Partners a Monumental Milestone they're
hoping to build on knowing all too well
not all paths lead to home if there's a
way
to keep family members safe
um you know and be proactive and then
let's do it Cali Stanton Global News
Victoria
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is an
overhead view of Niagara Falls in
Ontario Donna will be back with you
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
[Music]
thank you